trouve de ses trésors dans cette grange
de roswell vieille dépasse de backstage
des photos partout souvenirs d'une vie
folle celle du photographe michel rouger
un drôle de gars toujours au bon endroit
au bon moment
comme quand les rolling stones joue à
paris et que le photographe des lieux
est absent très mal tiré
le brésil fab ont j'étais tout jeune
photographe nous sommes en 1964 michel a
19 ans quand il signe sa première
pochette de disque pour tom jones aux
côtés d'un certain jean louis foulquier
futur patron des francofolies
il va croiser tous les plus grands
bourvil gainsbourg catherine lara oui
cela
cette photo a été prise sur un camion
sur un camion de fruits et légumes pas
loin de la place de la concorde ce qu'on
est parti de la rue monge jusqu'à la
place de la concorde où ça s'est terminé
avec trois cent mille personnes
quelque chose d'impossible aujourd'hui
il a tellement de chance eu tellement de
talent qu'à l'occasion de son service
militaire il accompagne le général de
gaulle au québec avec son fameux vive le
québec libre où nous avions ça c'est mon
labo photo j'avais monté à bord du
colvert des histoires aussi improbable
que celle-ci michel rouger en a plein
ses murs à chaque page du petit livre
qu'il publie
on le trouve sur la toile comme dans les
bonnes librairies de montargis de
nemours ou devient son titre parcours
d'un petit gars du xviie ce livre c'est
plutôt un carnet menottes accompagné de
photos que les gens ne peuvent pas voir
normalement les côtés plutôt coulisses
des artistes j'ai toujours fait partie
du dernier carré qui reste est
accompagné de l'artiste à 4 5 heures du
matin ces clichés 10 toute une époque
l'insouciance les rencontres qui
marquent une vie une certaine idée de
l'amitié la métier ça se définit selon
moi en deux mots être plat